YOU HAVE TO KEEP FASCISTS OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Tammy: THE MOST
CRINGEWORTHY MOMENT, THERE ARE
MORE, CAME FROM BILL CLINTON
HIMSELF.
I KNOW YOU’RE SURPRISED.
HERE IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT HIS
AFFAIR WITH MONICA LEWINSKY.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE OUR STAGGERI
AROUND, YOU HAVE BEEN IN A 15
ROUND PRIZE FIGHT THAT WAS
EXTENDED TO 30 ROUNDS.
AND HERE’S SOMETHING THAT WILL
TAKE YOUR MIND OFF OF IT FOR A
WHILE.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
EVERYBODY’S LIFE HAS PRESSURES
AND DISAPPOINTMENTS, TERRORS,
FEARS OF WHATEVER, THINGS I DID
TO MANAGE MINE, THINGS I DID FOR
YEARS.
>> Tammy: WOW, IT JUST NEVER
ENDS.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE WOMAN YOU
KNOW JUANITA BRODERICK ONE OF
BILL CLINTON’S ACCUSERS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT, I APPRECIATE IT.
IN 2004 WHEN HE WAS PROMOTING
HIS BIOGRAPHY, HE SAID THE
REASON THAT HE HAD THAT AFFAIR
WITH MONICA LEWINSKY AND DID
WHAT HE DID WAS BECAUSE HE
COULD.
NOW I AM GOING TO BELIEVE THAT
ANSWER, AS OPPOSED TO THIS ONE.
EVEN IF WE WERE TO BELIEVE HIM
THAT HE USED A WOMAN LIKE A
PRODUCT IN SOME WAY TO MANAGE
HIS ANXIETIES IS IN AND OF
ITSELF HORRIFIC, BUT HE SOUNDS
ALMOST AS THOUGH HE IS MAKING AN
EXCUSE THAT HE THINKS PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO APPRECIATE.
>> I KNOW, WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THAT TAMMY, I TWEETED AND
SAID WHAT IN HEAVEN’S NAME IS
GOING ON?
WILL THE NEXT EPISODE TALK ABOUT
THE WOMEN THAT HE?
THE WOMAN THAT HE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED?
WHERE CAN THEY POSSIBLY GO FROM
HERE?
I WAS ASTOUNDED.
>> Tammy: WHAT IS INTERESTING
TOO IS THERE IS A CATEGORY OF
VOTERS, SOME YOUNGER PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT NOT EVEN REALLY KNOW THE
DETAILS OF HIS HISTORY.
IT IS ALMOST PRESENTED AS THOUGH
THE MONICA LEWINSKY DYNAMIC, I
HAVE SEEN INTERVIEWS WITH HER,
SHE IS A BRIGHT WOMAN, HER LIFE
OF COURSE HAS BEEN CHANGED
FOREVER BECAUSE OF THIS, BUT IT
IS ALMOST AS THOUGH SHE IS
TRYING TO FIND A NEW WOKE
EXCUSE.
IF YOU ARE A VICTIM IN SOME WAY,
YOU ARE GOING TO GET A PASS ON
THIS.
DO YOU THINK, LOOK, ARE THESE
THINGS THAT THEY REALLY WANT TO
REMIND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT?
YOU HAVE BEEN HAVING TO DEAL
WITH THIS FOR SO LONG.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
HELPFUL TO THEM OR DO YOU THINK
IT WILL HURT THEM?
>> NO, I THINK PEOPLE WILL BE
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKED.
I THINK ABOUT ALL THE WOMEN THAT
ARE REALLY RIGHT HERE SITTING IN
THIS CHAIR WITH ME TONIGHT.
I THINK ABOUT KATHY SHELTON THE
YOUNG 12-YEAR-OLD, IN A COMA FOR
ALMOST A MONTH.
AND HILLARY PROVIDED ASSISTANCE
TO THE AND GOT HIM OFF, I THINK
ABOUT KATHLEEN, PAULA JONES, ALL
OF US.
THESE WERE ATTACKS, LONG BEFORE
MONICA LEWINSKY.
>> Tammy: I WANT TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT WHAT BILL
SAID ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
LEWINSKY AFTER EVERYTHING CAME
OUT.
IT TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I FEEL TERRIBLE ABOUT HOW IT
AFFECTED MONICA LEWINSKY’S LIFE.
UNFAIRLY, I THINK.
OVER THE YEARS, I HAVE WATCHED
HER TRYING TO GET HER NORMAL
LIFE BACK AGAIN.
>> Tammy: YEAH, YOU KNOW STILL
NO REAL APOLOGY.
HE FEELS BAD ABOUT THAT, DO YOU
THINK HE FEELS THE SAME ABOUT
YOU?
>> HE DOESN’T FEEL BAD ABOUT ANY
OF THIS.
HE JUST WANT SYMPATHY.
AND HE DIDN’T RIGHT THIS, LET ME
TELL YOU WHO WROTE THIS.
HILLARY WROTE THIS.
SHE DOESN’T WANT HIM TO GO
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT THERE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN FEELINGS FOR MONICA
LEWINSKY, SHE WAS JUST A TOY.
>> Tammy: I WILL TELL YOU
WANITA, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HUMAN CONDITION AND SO MANY
WOMEN HAVE HAD THE
EXPERIENCE OF EITHER
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
SEXUAL VIOLENCE, THE REMINDER OF
THIS AND ALSO TRYING TO ESCAPE
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
IT IS A REMARKABLE THING THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT BOTH OF
THEM WOULD FEEL COMFORTABLE
REMINDING PEOPLE OF END AS THOUG
THEY STILL HAVE A CLAIM TO FAME
OR STILL HAVE NO PROBLEM IN SO
MANY WAYS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
LIVES THAT THEY HAVE IMPACTED.
IT SEEMS TO BE AN EFFORT TO
REMAKE THEMSELVES OR TO AT LEAST
TELL A NEW GENERATION THAT THEY
ARE NOT TO BE BLAMED FOR
ANYTHING.
>> YEAH, TO ME, IT WAS
ABSOLUTELY UNREAL WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT IT.
THAT HULU COULD SUPPORT THIS
LOWLIFE PREDATOR AND COME OUT
WITH THIS NONSENSE, IT WAS A
VERY DISGUSTING AND DESPICABLE
THING TO ME.
IF YOU WANT THE GOOD NEWS IS, WE
ARE REMINDED ALL THE TIME ABOUT